. Also eine irgendeine Form von Special, sowas wie kein Gag damals. Ich habe das gleiche Gefühl wie damals, wo wir keinen Gag gemacht haben. Irgendwie, dass man was Neues macht. Wir haben noch nie so früh aufgenommen, noch nie um 12 Uhr. So eine Morningshow ist ein bisschen, so eine Ostermorning, ganz merkwürdige Kombination. Heute ist Ostag, Karfreitag. Karfreitag ist Jesus gestorben, ne? Er ist einfach gestorben, er wurde einfach ans Kreuz.
Und dann ist er gestorben, weil er ans Kreuz genagelt wurde?
Deswegen Kaff! gestorben, ne? Ist einfach gestorben, er wurde einfach ans Kreuz.
Und dann ist er gestorben, weil er ans Kreuz genagelt wurde? Deswegen K für Kreuz,
oder was? Ja, in Christus.
K für Kreuz? In Christus.
Aber er wurde ans Kreuz genagelt
und dann hat man nochmal eine Axt genommen und die in sein
Herz gerammt, ne? Ein Speer, ja.
Ein Speer.
Warum? Um zu sehen, ob er tot ist.
Aber hat man nicht den Zwei-Finger-Test an die Aorta? Wie, du meinst zwei Finger? Also, dass man so wie viele Fingerzeige gerade hat. Ja, genau. Den Wetten das und dann nochmal die Aktion testen, mit der Hand gegen die Augen. Ja, klasse. Damals wurde Thomas Gottschalk noch nicht geboren. Das heißt, das ganze Wissen, um wie stellt man fest, ob jemand sehen kann oder nicht, gab es damals nicht. Es gab ja wahnsinnig viele Blindenbetrüger damals im alten Rom, wahnsinnig viele Leute. Du meinst Blindenbetrüger, wo das eigentlich nur der Zwilling war, der nicht wirklich blind war. Genau, und dann wo der Zwilling von den Toten auferstanden ist und so. Ja, ja. Das wäre mal eine geile Serie, oder? So Rom-Con-Man, so Betrüger im alten Rom. Nee, also ich hatte mal einen Tweet, ich wollte da erst eine Reihe draus machen. Wie ging der denn nochmal? Ich glaube, Jesus hat nicht die Brote geteilt, er hatte nur sehr viele Brote in seinem Ärmel. Bei dem Blinden weiß man nicht, wie er es gemacht hat. Genau, ja. Aber er ist einfach ein Scammer. Er ist einfach so ein Möchtegern-Magier, so diese Street-Magicians, die man heute kennt, wie von Facebook oder so, aber halt im alten Jerusalem.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine, da gab es ja wahnsinnig viele Religionen und Sekten und so, das ist ja heute wie, keine Ahnung, Social-Media-Plattformen, wo ganz viele verschiedene Firmen um deine Aufmerksamkeit buhlen und irgendwann legt sich das dann fest. Damals war es halt so, es gab ganz viele verschiedene Religionen und die jetzt alle natürlich vergessen sind, weil die Kirche hat dann irgendwann die alle verbran die Dokumente und so und die Konterbibel und die Nibel und die Giebel, die damals alle rausgebracht wurden, hat man ja alle verbrennen lassen, weil man das nicht toleriert hat. Warum reich nicht durchreißen? Ihr hört euch am Verbrennen, ey, das macht euch nicht so viel, einfach durchreißen, schön viele kleine Schnipsel, das niemand gibt, sie macht sich die Mühe, obwohl die hatten Langeweile. Die hatten schon Langeweile früher. Viel Langeweile. Aber hast du schon mal was geschreddert? Ja, echt? Oh, früher als Kind haben wir einen Schredder gehabt. Ja. Aber meinst du jetzt diese Papierschredder, diese Aktenzerstörung? Nee, ich meine den Bösewicht aus Turtles. Nee, es gibt aber auch im Garten Schredder, wo man dann wirklich lange Ätze reinmachen kann. Der macht dann also der wird immer lauter, je doll mal reindrückt und dann kommt unten Rindenmulch raus. Immer Rindenmulch, egal was du reinmachst oben, unten kommt Rindenmulch raus. Auch deine Schwester oben rein, Rindenmulch, immer egal was bei sich. Plastik-Klettergerüst, unten kommt Rindenmulch raus. Ja, aber nee, ich meine jetzt tatsächlich den Papierschredder. Ja, habe ich auch mal, als ich früher mal in der Einkaufsabteilung gearbeitet habe in Sommerferien, da habe ich oft Akten zerschreddert. Das war glaube ich mein einziger Job auch. Wobei das war halt keine wichtige Firma, wo es irgendwie wichtige Dokumente gab, so X-Files mässig, wo man sich auch fragt, warum... X-Files? Ja, so X-Files, so CIA und so, da verstehe ich, warum die Aktenschredder haben.
Damit die Aliens nicht nachgucken, ob sie jetzt gut rüberkamen mit der Folge oder nicht. Ja, richtig, wenn so Verschwörungstheoretiker reinkommen, dass sie nichts finden oder dass die Dinge schwärzen müssen. Aber warum so eine ganz normale Firma, die, weiß ich nicht, Frischkäse herstellt, warum die ausgerechnet Aktenzerstörer haben wollen. Aber auch da einfach, es gibt ja diese Szene aus
Bella Corsoil, wo er sich diese ganzen Säcke
aus dem Altpapier holt und dann aus
den Streifen die ganzen Akten
wiederherstellt, wo er denn ganz
viel Streifen hat, unglaubliche Arbeit,
aber es ist zumindest möglich. Es war die ganze
Staffel, hat er das dann zusammengebaut. Das ist eine
sehr langsam erzählte Serie, muss man mal
sagen, dann hat er die ganze Staffel, bestand nur daraus,
wie man ihn von oben so übersichtlich gezeigt hat, wie er das zusammengesetzt hat, diese Akten wieder auszunehmen. Vor allem die Extended Edition, ich habe ja die DVD-Box, die Extended Edition, noch mal weitere fünf Stunden nur Zusammensätze von Akten. Und man denkt sich so, oh, passt das zusammen? Nee. Auch im Audiokommentar, das, was sie sich vorher zurückgelegt haben, zu sagen, haben sie auch geschreddert. Das heißt, auch die sind die ganze Zeit daran. Vor allem, woher weißt du, welche Seite du willst? Es kann sein, dass du monatelang an einer Seite bastelst und dann ist es so dieses Deckblatt oder so. Wo nochmal vielen Dank für die Zusammenarbeit, Agent sowieso, Special Agent, und dann denkst du, fuck, ja, aber worum geht's? Und dann war alles umsonst. Dann musst du nochmal zusammensetzen, andere Seiten. Hätte er es verbrannt? Ich weiß nicht, ob das genau rauskam bei der Szene, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wo die hinführt, aber es war auf jeden Fall ... Aber ich freue mich wieder auf die nächste Staffel. Das geht immer bei der Cold Soul. Ich weiss nicht warum, irgendwie ist die ganze Zeit, man denkt, jetzt passiert was. Und jetzt kommt Walter White rein. Man denkt die ganze Zeit, jetzt muss es doch mal irgendwann zu einem Höhepunkt kommen, aber wirklich seit vier Staffeln dümpelt da diese Brudergeschichte vor sich rum. Hast du es gesehen? Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es gar nicht zu angeschaut. Ich habe die zweite Staffel gar nicht angefangen. Ich bin so ein Einstaffeltyp. Ich schaue eine Staffel und dann denke ich mir so, ja, passt schon. Reicht jetzt auch. Weil man hat ja oft nur eine Idee für eine Staffel. Wenn dir eine Serie einfällt, dann hast du ja nicht gleich die Idee für vier Staffeln. Nee, das ist ja bescheuert. Oder wie ist das, Stefan? Kannst du da was zu erzählen? Nee, ich kann dazu nichts sagen. Wollen wir kurz ins Lokale gehen? Ja. Jingle? Lokales. Und zwar auf der Fenloa. Wir müssen dringend wieder anfangen, Geld auszugeben für unsere Jingles. Ja, seit unser Jingles-Supervisor leider, leider verstorben ist, Kopf verloren, ist es nicht mehr so leicht. Fenlo, Fenloer Straße gibt es ja
so einen Spielplatz mit so einer Wand,
wo die lokalen Graffiti-Künstler
sich so ein bisschen austoben können. Graffiti?
Die so ein bisschen mal gucken können, die sprayen
dann so ihre Tags und ihre
Pictures und so. Aber meistens,
hast du das verstanden? Diese Tags
sind meistens doch nur T-D-U,
Gebo, T-F-D,
Dumbo, K-B-B, Rebel, ZHK, Spike, ja, wer ist Spike? Alter! Irgendwo da draußen ist Spike, vielleicht hört Spike gerade zu und denkt sich, Alter, dieses jahrzehntelange Taggen hat was gebracht, ich habe den PR-Erfolg, der mir damals versprochen wurde. Spike und Ted. Und ich mag das ja immer so, also ein bisschen Graffiti ist ja genau meins, also so ein bisschen Urban Culture und so, ich gucke da immer gerne hin irgendwie. Wenn du eine Snapback-Cap auf hast. Für mich ist das auch Kunst, so. Also für mich, ich sehe nicht, warum das eine im Museum hängt, und das andere wird wieder entfernt von der Stadt, das verstehe ich nicht, weil für mich ist das alles eins. Für dich ist alles Streetart für dich. Das ist für mich, gehört einfach zusammen. Spike ist Streetart? Spike ist für mich Streetart. Jetzt wurde ja in Dings dieses Gebäude abgerissen, wo ganz viele Graffiti war. Und dann hat der Gebäude-Eigentümer gesagt, Leute, das ist mein Haus, ich mache das kaputt, wann immer ich will. Und dann haben aber alle gesagt, nee, da war unsere Kunst drin, haben gewonnen, 60 Millionen Dollar bekommen. Anderes Thema. Moment, ganz kurz. Zu Spike. Ganz kurz. Es ist wahnsinnig früh, sorry, ich krieg's nicht ganz auf die Reine. Und das reicht denen nicht, die haben zusätzlich 60 Millionen bekommen. Ja, na klar, ein Gewinn ist ja immer mit was, du kannst ja nicht sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt das Spiel gewonnen, aber ich krieg keinen Preis. Ja, ich glaube, du musst die Fakten nochmal klar bekommen. Nee, die Fakten waren völlig korrekt. Und jetzt laufe ich hier so vorbei, Graffiti, ich gucke mir das mal an, aus so einem Stil, so einem Sprühstil, irgendwie so Übergang und so.
Ja, nee, nee, Renaissance.
Und da war eine große Pflanze mit einem Marienkäfer drauf, also als Bild, nicht echt.
Ach so.
Okay, jetzt werden wir nicht, jetzt drehen wir mal nicht durch gerade.
Ich sag gerade, sorry, einen überraschenden Turn.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ten Turns.
Also Motiv des Graffiti-Sprays, sagt man ja, so eine Wand, so als abgestoßt. Genau, ein Spray. Und das ist so eine Pflanzenwelt mit einem Marienkäfer drauf. Meine Theorie, und alle Kölner Wendloher Gänger, alle Artliebhaber, Artheads, können da mich korrigieren oder bestätigen. Und zwar, glaube ich, hat dieser Graffiti-Künstler gemerkt, dass der Marienkäfer auf dem Blatt ein bisschen zu gross ist. Ja, der Marienkäfer ist zu gross. So, und jeder kennt das, so man malt ein Bild, man fängt in der Mitte an. Und jetzt fängt es nämlich an, das ist nämlich so, wenn man Getränke mixt und von dem einen zu viel reinmacht, dann macht man von dem anderen Zutat mehr rein und es wird immer voller. Das ist die nächste Staffel Better Call Saul. Wo er nur so ein Gin Tonic und immer. Acht Liter Rum Cola. Weil du musst halt, es ist halt normal. Wahrscheinlich hat er angefangen, dann das Blatt grösser zu malen, korrekt? Und jetzt, jeder kennt das so, du malst ein Pferd auf dem Blatt Papier und du malst den Kopf in die Mitte. Und du denkst dir, wie dumm bin ich eigentlich, warum mal ich den Kopf in die Mitte? Du fängst die Happy Birthday-Karte in der Mitte an, Happy zu schreiben. Und dann das Y geht schon so um die Ecke. Happy Bit? Naja, also halt, alles Gute. Und naja, jetzt ist die Frage, was macht man als Graffiti-Head so irgendwie, wenn du jetzt irgendwie so ein Blatt... Ja, ich glaube, so nennt man die nicht. Marineienkäfer ist viel zu gross. Und die Idee von Spike war folgende, pass auf. Hm, der Marienkäfer ist zu gross. Hm, wie könnte man das noch irgendwie realistisch ins Bild integrieren? Ich male eine Lupe um den Marienkäfer drumrum, als wäre das so reingezoomt. Aber man sieht ganz genau, dass die Lupe erst im Nachhinein eingefügt wurde, weil die Lupe macht ja nicht nur den Marinekäfer grösser, sondern alles andere im Hintergrund auch, was in der Lupe ist, man kennt das, der Bereich in der Lupe ist dann vergrössert, war nicht der Fall. Der Hintergrund war exakt gleich und man sieht ganz genau, und da können jetzt wirklich irgendwie die Locals, die Streetpeeps, können da irgendwie das für mich überprüfen. Ich glaube, und da kann Spike gerne was dazu sagen, dass diese Lupe im Nachhinein dazugesprayt wurde und nicht ursprünglich in seinem eigenen Spray veranlagt war. Ja, aber warum kommt man auf die Idee, also man ist ja, für mich ist es immer eine wahnsinnig coole, unantastbare Welt. So, die tragen alle, die hören alle Hip-Hop, die können alle Breakdancen zwischendurch und malen dann halt nebenbei, machen die dieses Es ist ja immer ein Kinderzahn drin, ne? Genau. Und sprühen halt dran und die haben auch keine Masken, weil das so uncool ist. Und dann sprühen sie aber Müssen oft husten, aber auch cool, weil die haben halt diesen Raucherhusten, diesen jahrelang antrainierten Höhö. Und dann spielen sie dran und dann entscheiden sie sich für einen Marienkäfer? Entschuldigung, darf ist für mich irgendwann diese Neo-Graffiti. Ja, ich glaube, das ist halt wieder so eine, das ist halt, ich glaube, Ironie funktioniert genau wie Rum-Cola. So, du musst immer mehr reinkippen, damit es wieder ironisch ist.
Und dann, sobald es wieder nicht stimmt.
Damit haben wir den Rum-Cola-Effekt.
Den können wir mal so nennen.
Der Rum-Cola-Effekt.
Man muss, um das wieder auszugleichen,
das Mischverhältnis immer mehr hinzufügen,
hat am Ende mehr, als man will.
Und es gibt ja kein richtiges Mischverhältnis,
das ist ja eine Illusion.
Du bist ja immer nur näherungsweise.
Und bei Ironie ist es auch so ein bisschen,
wenn du halt Graffiti-Künstler bist und alle machen so den Teufel oder was die halt so machen. Okay, die machen den Teufel. Und Tonköpfe. Pontius Pilatus und so, krass. Und dann denkst du dir so, okay, ich will mich davon abheben, also mache ich eine Blume. und dann machst du eine Blume und dann sagt der andere, okay, ich mache den Käfer, der die Blume frisst. Und dann sagt der andere, oh, ich mache... Wir müssen langsam mal wieder einen Teufel meinen, sonst ist es wieder so ungut. Aber die Reaktion auf den Marienkäfer ist dann wieder, oh, ich mache das Chameleon. Chameleon, wie man in Spanien sagt. Oh, geil. Ach so, ich meine, dass er den Marienkäfer frisst, das ist immer so ein Scheinsterepapier. Also man sagt, Chameleons sind gute Tarnkünstler, aber ich würde behaupten, man sieht sie noch sehr häufig. Die kriegen das nicht so richtig hin. Manche Pigmente machen mit. So, okay, ich bin rot jetzt, ich bin rot, wir sind vom roten Hintergrund, aber viele Sachen kriegen das noch nicht hin. Hast du das genau verstanden, wie das funktioniert? Wie genau nehmen diese Pigmente, die Farben wahr? Naja, ich glaube, das ist so die Frage, also das Chameleon, Chameleon muss schon das sehen. Weil die haben doch auch diese 360 Grad Facebook. Also du meinst, was sie sehen, also wird auf die drauf projiziert. Also sozusagen, also wenn die Fernsehen gucken, dann kann man auf denen auch Fernsehen gucken. Ja, wenn du die auf dem Fernseher sitzt. Naja, ich glaube, die sind... Nee, du hast gerade gesagt, was die sehen, ist auf denen drauf. Hä? Nee, was sie halt in ihrer Umgebung wahrnehmen. Wie so ein Verlängerungskabel. Stell dir mal vor, du würdest immer das, was du gerade anschaust, so würdest du aussehen. Ja. Also wenn du gerade eine Vase anschaust, bist du selbst auch eine Vase. Sehr verwirrend, weil alles sich andauernd verändert, die ganze Zeit. Und dann schaut gerade irgendwie die Freundin schaut das Chameleon an, wird auch zur Vase und dann wird es total absurd. Ja, genau, ein Perpetuum mobile und am Ende ist die ganze Welt eine große Vase. So, das gibt bestimmt Paralleldimensionen, wo genau das passiert ist. Es gibt noch ein paar Religionen, die davor Angst haben, dass das passiert. Der Vasentag naht. Oder so was? Aber viel verrückter als Ramellions finde ich ja Pflanzen. Weil es gibt Pflanzen, Pflanzen sind klüger, als man denkt. Punkt eins. Punkt zwei, es gibt eine Pflanze, die ähnlich funktioniert wie Ramellions. Kein Spaß. Es ist tatsächlich so, das ist so eine Kletterpflanze. Und Kletterpflanzen sind ja schon die klugen Pflanzen. Weil die sparen sich den Stamm. Die hängen sich halt an andere dran. Also sie sind schon mal besser. Kletten gibt es auch. Kletterpflanzen. Und was diese Pflanze macht, ist, die imitiert die Blattform der Pflanze, an der sie hochklettert. What? What? Und das ist wirklich so. Alter Pflanze! Ich habe einen Artikel in der Zeit gelesen, in der aktuellen Zeit könnt ihr nachlesen, und zwar haben die Botaniker auch ausprobiert, die waren halt in China unterwegs oder irgendwie sowas im Dschungel, und dann haben die gesagt, krass, ist uns noch nie aufgefallen, dass sie das imitiert, lass uns mal irgendwie so Fantasiepflanzen vom chinesischen Markt kaufen, so Teufelspflanzen und so, die halt die Chinesen mögen, die lieben das. Drachenwut. Ja, und dann halt so Fantasy-Pflanzen und dann haben die auch an diese Fantasy-Pflanzen reingeklebt und die haben tatsächlich auch die Fantasy-Blätter imitiert. Also die haben wirklich erfundene Pflanzen genommen und die haben das dann auch imitiert. Genau, Plastikpflanzen, die es so nicht in der Natur gibt, haben daran die Trank, weil die dachten halt, vielleicht können die irgendwie durch, dass sie das fühlen oder dass sie halt irgendwie die Duftstoffe, die Duftstoffe wahrnehmen, aber es ist tatsächlich visuell. Die müssen auf irgendeine Art sehen können, wie die Blätter aussehen. Man könnte sich vorstellen, der kennt halt zehn Gerüche oder zehn whatever von Pflanzen und dann weiss der halt, okay, die Pflanze riecht so, also bilde ich diese Pflanzen aus. Das ist halt irgendwie so in den DNA veranlagt. Aber so ist es nicht. Der kann wirklich dynamisch sehen, also sehen ist natürlich das falsche Wort, aber irgendwie wahrnehmen. Also das ist richtig crazy. Ich meine, ich finde es cool, also es ist ein bisschen bedeutend, wo man sagt, cooles Talent und jetzt so, was macht ihr damit jetzt mit dem Talent? Also diese Pflanze, cool, dass sie es kann. Also wirklich große Komplimente. Danke, dass ihr hier sind, Pflanze. Ja, wir rufen zurück. Aber was genau, also was bringt das jetzt? Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass sie sich so gegen Fressfeinde schützen, weil die irgendwie... Und sich dann aus Versehen, die Pflanze verändert, die die Leute essen wollen. Stell dir mal vor, die Gastgeberpflanze ist giftig und die Gastpflanze nicht. Und dann sagte ich meine Zubelette genauso wie die giftige Pflanze. Und dann alle, die an Scheißpflanzen kleben, werden ja gefressen oder die an coolen Pflanzen leben, gehen weiter. Wie sieht die Fault mästig aus, die Pflanze? Ich glaube, da es eine Kletterpflanze ist, gibt es keinen Default, weil die muss immer an irgendwas dranhängen. Und die haben tatsächlich, es gibt auch soziale Pflanzen. Es gibt Pflanzen, die in irgendeiner Weise mit Geruchsstoffen, mit anderen Pflanzen interagieren und zum Beispiel, ich glaube, Sonnenblumen oder so und dann haben die eine Sonne, da gibt es so ein Feld von Sonnenblumen und dann haben die eine Pflanze genommen und in ein anderes Feld eingepflanzt. Ja, das ganze Feld, nein! Nein! Nein! Und die Pflanze ist eingegangen, die ist gestorben. Ja, weil die die in den Keller gestellt haben. Nee, weil die die in dieses Feld von den anderen Pflanzen eingeben. Und es war tatsächlich auch so, dass die teilweise aus anderen Gegenden Pflanzen genommen haben. Und die haben dann anders auf die anderen Pflanzen reagiert. Also die gehen davon aus, dass es so eine Form von Dialekten gibt, auch in den Geruchsstoff-Pheromonsystemen, dass sie in anderen Gebieten anders sprechen. Und dann kommt diese Pflanze, ja, servus Christi, was ist jetzt los? Und die sagt, sorry, noch mal, noch mal bitte. Und dann sagt die Pflanze, geht die so ein. Und hier ist dein ganzes Wasser weg. Okay, ihr merkt, dass die monothematische Pflanzen vorgeheut wird. Ey, total verrückt, aber da habe ich mir echt gedacht, krass. Pflanzenwelt ist schon krank. Pflanzenwelt ist richtig krank. Ich glaube auch, dass Algen die Zukunft sind. Ja, ja, die produzieren auch sehr viel Sauerstoff. Weil durch den Klimawandel wird ja irgendwann alles Wasser sein. Ich habe ja irgendwann mal erzählt, dass ich diese Meeresbiologie-Magazine geschickt bekommen habe. Und die lese ich jetzt auch gerade. Fünf Magazine, ich habe jetzt schon zwei gelesen. Und die sagen da von wegen, was man gegen den Klimawandel machen kann. Und in den Niederlanden werden schon so schwimmende Häuser gebaut, die dann halt so einfach so... Boote. Und fliegende Häuser werden auch gebaut. Und die machen auch so Unterwasserhäuser, machen die. Ja, genau. Und so Häuser auf Rädern, das ist total ... Weil dann können die wegfahren, wenn die das Wasser kommt. Das machen die in Holland schon länger. Das ist total abgefahren. Und die haben auch so Häuser auf Beinen. Alter, wenn das denn ... Die ganze Zeit dieses Ideen ... Alle machen sich immer über die Wohnmobil-Holländer lustig, mit dem Wohnwagen.
Ja! Aber es ist einfach die schlauste
Idee der Welt, weil das Volk einfach
wegfahren kann. Ja, ein ziehendes
Volk. Ja, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen die Idee von
Niederlande auch, dass sie halt so flach
sind, dass sie jede Sekunde weg sein können.
Du lebst in einem Land, das einfach von heute auf morgen weg ist
und dann so packen wir es woanders hin.
Aber du warst stehen geblieben bei deinem
Unterwassermagazin. Richtig, und Algen sind die Zukunft, weil je mehr Wasser es gibt, desto wichtiger werden Algen. Deswegen versuche ich jetzt auch schon viele Algen zu essen, um mich daran zu gewöhnen, dass wenn irgendwann nur noch Algen gegessen werden. Und Algen sind dann billig und Landseite. Was du nicht seht, Flo, hat einen ganz ungesunden Aufschlag, die Hälfte ist in der Nase, ist irgendwie weg, eine Augenbraue fehlt komplett und überall sind Pflanzenreste auf ihm drauf. Übrigens, wir haben ja in der letzten Folge angesprochen, ganz kurz, wir müssen erstmal Lokales wieder zumachen, bitte. Lokales. Und Community? Community. Wir brauchen bessere Jingles. Und Community, wir haben uns in der letzten Folge über das Entenfüttern geredet. Das stimmt. Im Rentner-Cast-Teil. Und dann habe ich mal die verrückte Idee rausgehauen, könnte man nicht auch Nudeln an Enten füttern? Es klingt wie so ein Traum, wenn man sich nicht erinnert, was in der letzten Folge... Ein Großteil der Enten in Deutschland leben jetzt nicht mehr. Und tatsächlich hat jemand einen Artikel geschickt, dass man auf gar keinen Fall Nudeln verfüttern soll. Richtig? Deswegen ganz kurz, ganz kurz Jingle für Warenrückzug. Oder wie sagt man Revision? Revision! Die in der letzten Folge, Folge 129 gemachte Aussage, dass Enten mit Nudeln gefüttert werden sollen, möchten wir hiermit dringlichst zurückziehen. Auf gar keinen Fall. Grosses Sorry an die Enten-Community, grosses Entschuldigung. Wir schicken euch einen Präsentkorb ohne Nudeln. Einfach einen Präsentkorb mit Broten, verschiedene, dass ihr essen könnt, aber bitte da draußen keine Nudeln verfüttern. Und deswegen ein Gedenkquark hier an der Stelle, in Gedenken an alle gestorbenen Enten. Quark! Und die haben kein Echo. Enten haben kein Echo. Jetzt könnte man aufhören, aber nein, wir haben noch nicht mal richtig angefangen. Mein Name ist Florentin Will und mir gegenüber sitzt Stefan De Calzone Tizze und... Wo kommt das denn? Genau, genau, genau. Wir sind ein bisschen verwirrt, denn heute ist Karfreitag, Ostern, wir sind in Osterlaune. Wir haben heute tatsächlich unseren Ostertisch ausgepackt. Wann will jetzt jetzt wieder Aufnahme an? Ja, der aussieht wie ein grosses Ei und es ist wahnsinnig früh morgens. Und ich dachte mir ... Es ist auch schon warm geworden. Stefan und ich haben den Aufnahmezeitpunkt festgelegt und er so, ja, 11 Uhr oder 12 Uhr. Und ich so Feiertag, so geht's auch später als zwölf? Und er so, nee, zwölf ist schon gut. Ich dachte mir, gut, Stefan muss viel arbeiten. Ich dachte, er fängt um die sieben Uhr morgens, er schlürft da ins Büro, irgendwie ballert den ganzen Tag, komm mich hier an, kommt er gähnt irgendwie auch irgendwie gerade das an. Und so ein Zahnpasta im Gesicht und so ein Nutella noch. Auch gerade aufgeschaltet. Und wie kommst du auf die wahnwitzige Idee, dass zwölf Uhr eine gute Aufnahmezeit wäre? Du kennst doch diese Euphorie, die man am Vortag hat, wo man sagt, morgen mache ich, da stehe ich eher auf, beginne den Tag vernünftig, damit ich was vom Tag habe, morgen ist Schuss, Wetter, schön um zwölf, aber ich habe es einfach so als Zeit mal ausgehauen. Und da habe ich mich auch schon gefragt, warum stellt er das jetzt in Frage, ist zwölf Uhr so eine inhumane Zeit? Aber ja, und dann ist man, das merkt man aber erst, wenn man dann selber aufsteht. Zwölf Uhr an einem Feiertag ist acht Uhr an einem normalen Tag. So, da willst du nichts mit anderen Menschen zu tun haben. Oh, das ist auch eine ganz unangenehme Zeit, das stimmt schon. Wo dann auch, man merkt das in Köln immer, wenn die U-Bahnen die fahren, nicht die neuen U-Bahnen sind, sondern diese alten. Die Scham-U-Bahnen. Ja, und dann hast du einfach, also gefühlt sitzt du auf so einem Block Stein. Also das hat nicht mehr was, du hast nicht mehr diese ergonomischen Sitze, wo du dann so reinflätzen kannst und dann so noch schlafen kannst in der Umbahn, nein, das ist einfach so wie so eine Pritsche. Das heißt so eine halbe Morningshow, ich hoffe, ihr seid gut aus dem Bett gekommen, seid aufgeschnitten. Ey, weißt du was, wir machen heute mal so eine Start in den Tag Folge. Oh, Leute. Ich habe heute zwei Croissants geholt, schön mit Nutella rein. Aber auch da war das Mischverhältnis nicht gut. Zu viel Nutella. Aber dann brauchte ich mehr Croissant. Tatsächlich, die, ich möchte mal, die Kamps-Apfeltaschen wurden geändert. Man kriegt das ja oft nicht mit. Und die Kamps-Apfeltaschen waren ja wirklich immer so, das war ein richtiger Beutel. Ja, da hat man gesagt, das ist für mich eine Apfeltasche.
Also das war keine Tasche mehr, das war ein Beutel, muss man sagen.
Und das war wirklich dreidimensional, das ist nicht eine Apfeltasche, hat mir irgendwas Flaches vor.
Ja, das ist Briefförmiges, nee, nee.
Das war wirklich wie eine Kalzone, es war eine Apfelkalzone.
Apfelkoffer.
Und das war verrückt, weil du konntest wirklich da einmal reinbeißen und dann es fast auslöffeln. Oder so ein Strohhalm, so viel Apfelkram. Mega Apfel. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was das ist. Also das ist Apfel und dann so Soßen, also so Apfel. Ja, das ist Apfel. Was ist Apfelkompott? Ja gut, aber vor allem verschiedene Formen des Apfels. Also bei manchen hat man gesagt, die sind geschnitten, nimmt man jetzt schon raus, sind da auch Apfelstücke drin. Stückchen, ja. Und dann hat man gesagt, ne, den Rest, den verarbeiten wir noch weiter zur Flüssigkeit. Und dann kommt noch Zimt rein wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß es nicht genau, Zimt war drin, vor allem das war zu Weihnachtszeit, hieß es nicht die Apfeltasche, sondern die Weihnachtsapfeltasche. Und dann war Zimt drin und ich dachte mir, jetzt muss ich ganz viele Apfeltaschen essen, weil es die nur zu Weihnachten gibt. Und dann stellt sich raus, die gibt es das ganze Jahr, nur halt dann ohne Zimt und ich glaube mittlerweile, dass da immer Zimt drin ist.
Ostertasche, Osterapfeltasche.
Auf jeden Fall, die wurde jetzt geändert, ist jetzt flacher und jetzt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
auch wenn Apfel, wenn einem Apfel genommen wird, ist eigentlich immer schlecht,
aber mittlerweile ist das Verhältnis besser.
Wollte ich nur mal ganz kurz wieder.
Ich muss seit Ostern immer daran denken, wie ich eine Woche bei einer Radiokomedy-Produktionsfilmer gearbeitet habe.
Die haben halt... Die dunkelste Woche im Leben. Ja, ich dachte wirklich, die haben bestimmt gute Laune, die machen ja immer Comedy und so. Stellt sich raus, das ist ein so trauriges Büro gewesen. Die taten mir richtig leid. Nehmen wir mal so ein Tonstudio, kommen wir mal Leute, ja und dann sprechen die halt ein. Und hier ist ein Schreibtisch, setze ich einfach hin und... Ja, wir haben jetzt nächste Woche Ostern und ich habe... Ich sitze seit sieben Jahren hier und jedes Jahr die scheisse Oster-Gags. Und immer an Ostern muss ich an dieses Büro denken, weil die sich schon wieder Oster-Gags überlegen müssen. Alter. Und jedes Jahr müssen die dann Oster-Gags. Und Ostern ist ein begrenztes Fest. Ich habe auch gestern mit einem Kollegen darüber gesprochen, weil man sich so frohe Ostern gewünscht hat, wo man nicht genau weiß, was gibt man dem anderen damit jetzt auf den Weg. Also an Weihnachten gibt es so ein gewisses Mindset, frohe Weihnachten. Das schwingt mit Behaglichkeit. Mal runterkommen. Mal runterkommen. Ja, Abschluss. Schenkt was, Fest der Liebe. Ja, Familie. Man weiß auch direkt, wenn der andere frohe Weihnachten wünscht, man hat so ein Bild im Kopf, was der macht, er holt sich einen Baum, stellt ihn hin, aber einem erwachsenen Menschen frohe Ostern zu wünschen, ist so ein bisschen, ist ein großes Fragezeichen für sich im Kopf. Was macht er denn jetzt? Er will sich einfach nach Hause um den Sofa legen und Netflix gucken und dann wird er in den Filmen kommen, in ein paar Wochen. Das ist total merkwürdig. Es ist seltsam. Und deshalb muss ich mal an diese Firma denken, die dann da jetzt sitzen und wahrscheinlich mit so Tränen. Wenn der Rest des Landes immer den Oster-Counter macht, so fünf, vier und alle ... Wow! Und Schnitt in diesen Redaktionsraum. Ja, Suizidgedanken. Aber was haben die da für Arten von Gags gemacht? Viel Ei natürlich irgendwie. Viel Ei-Gags, viel Hasen-Gags. Freiwillig und viel Ei, es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele deutsche Worte mit Ei. Ja, ja, Einsamkeit. Immer hat sich diese Traurigkeit auch in die Gags projiziert. Leiden. Leiden. Angsthase, Angst, Mord. Er ist ein trauriges Büro, man stellt sich das immer so lustig vor, aber Comedy ist oft einfach harte Arbeit. Ja, vor allem, ich glaube, da ist der Überschnitt, wenn du, sag mal, Anspruch, wir machen keine Eier-Eier-Gags, haha, dicke Eier, aber wir wollen trotzdem Oster-Gags machen, dann bist du in dieser Deadzone, in dieser No-Man's Land der Comedy, wo du einfach, du hast nicht die guten Ideen für richtig gute Gags, aber du bist hier zu gut, um die schlechten Gags zu machen, und dann bist du in diesem Limbo, wo einfach nichts entsteht. Limbo, hallo? Oh, hallo, hallo, hallo? Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gäcks, Gllo? Hallo, hallo, hallo? Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags,
Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags, Gags,
Ey, das ist ja wirklich, habe ich das eigentlich mal gesagt, aber ich habe meinen Gitarrenlehrer mal gesagt und ich war wirklich für drei Wochen verändert.
Ich war ein anderer Mensch, weil ich dachte mir, what the fuck, das ist das Lustigste, was ich je gehört habe.
Und ich dachte mir, krass, wie man Sprache manipulieren kann.
Und zwar, ich glaube, der Gag funktioniert nur im Bayerischen, aber so dieses
der Bayer
kommt nach Amerika
und dann sagt er immer,
sorry, es ist spontan,
ist nicht immer leicht, und dann sagt er so von wegen
so, die englische Sprache ist
merkwürdig.
So, Achtung,
i, also wie der Bayer sagt, ich, I heisst I und im Englischen I, ich, also I heisst I, I heisst Egg.
Im Englischen?
Ja.
Egg heisst Corner und Corner heißt Nobody. Folgst du mir so weit? Ja. Also ich bin niemand. Nee, es ist einfach nur die Worte, so Eck wie Ecke. Im bayerischen Eck, Eck heißt Corner und Corner heißt Nobody, wie im bayerischen Corner, keiner. I heißt I, I heißt Eck, Eck heißt Corner und Corner heißt Nobody. Und ich habe ungefähr genau gegenteilig wie du reagiert. reagiert. Ich dachte mir, holy shit, what the fuck, mal ganz kurz alle herhören, Leute, alle, alle gerade mal, alle. Im Nebenraum spielst du die Posaune, was, was, der Schlagzeugspiel im Nebenraum immer, unerbeinig davon, einfach sehr nervig. Die ganze Zeit. Aber, Alter, da dachte ich mir, krass, Und das verbinde ich immer noch mit Ostern, wegen Ei und Egg und Ostern-Gags, muss ich immer dran denken. Stefan, hey, hey, du hast die Augen zu, Stefan. Komm zurück, wo bist du gerade? Du bist im Osterlimbo, komm zurück, Corner, verstehst du? Corner, wie Corner Shop. Also I, I, I ist Egg, Egg ist Corner, Corner ist Nobody. Richtig. Und geht das noch weiter? Naja, weil Nobody wird es dann schwer. Ja gut, aber vielleicht kann man es so fortführen. Aber nur so viel zum Thema Eiergags zu Ostern. Also wenn ich da gearbeitet hätte bei diesem Radio-Ding, wäre das sofort mein erster Gag gewesen, vielleicht auch mein letzter. Viele Autofahrer werden im Sekundenschlaf bei der Radiokomedi leider gegen den Baum gefahren. Aber apropos Sprachgags, ich weiß nicht, welcher Präsident es war, aber ein Präsident hat man eine Rede gehalten, und zwar vor so einer Gruppe Südkoreaner. Also in Südkorea, glaube ich, Seoul oder keine Ahnung, so ein riesengroßer Platz mit Menschen. Wo? Seoul. Seoul. Seoul. Wie spricht man diese Stadt aus? Seoul, glaube ich, etwa. Aber es ist doch ein E da drin. Ja, das können wir doch nicht einfach ignorieren. Hat dann Rede gehalten, hat dann auch einen Gag gemacht. Und der Übersetzer hat den Gag übersetzt an das Volk und das Volk ist in Lachen ausgebrochen. Die haben gelacht, das hat man noch nicht gesehen. So sehr, dass, ich glaube, Carter war es, der seine Rede unterbrochen hat und gesagt hat, Entschuldigung, wie hast du das geschafft, diesen Gag zu übersetzen, dass er so gut ankam und vor allem in einer anderen Sprache und so viel Lacher bekommen hat. Und hat er übersetzt, er hat gesagt, naja, er hebt ihn gesagt, das ist eine lustige Story, die sollen alle ganz kurz lachen. Und dann hat er gelacht. Wie gut. Aber wie lustig das ist, dass die einfach dann gelacht haben. Das ist schon geil. Und er übersetzt hat die dazu gezwungen. Und vor allem, das stellt auch in Frage,, was er da vorgesagt hat. Erstmal ist es eine diplomatisch schwierige Zeit gewesen, wo man sagen kann, okay, wenn der Übersetzer ein paar Fehler macht, Weltkrieg. Und dieser Übersetzer hat nicht nur Fehler gemacht, er hat sich auch einfach rausgenommen, sowas zu sagen wie, er hat diesen Geck jetzt nicht übersetzt, er hat eine lustige Story erzählt, bitte lachen auf drei, zwei, eins und eins und. Und wo man auch da sagt, okay, alles, was er da vorgesagt hat, wird doch in Frage gestellt. Aber ich finde, es ist eine tolle Botschaft eigentlich. Aber auch toll, dass er es zu gibt. Auch dass das Volk bereit ist, das eigene Humorverständnis für die diplomatischen Beziehungen aufzugeben, zu sagen, höflichkeitshalber, also ein ganzes Volk lacht Höflichkeitshalber. Und alle schon wirklich so, 20.000 Menschen spielen so gut, lachen, dass er sagt, wow, cool, ja, mein Hasengag davor, habt ihr nicht so gedacht. Vor allem in einer alternativen Welt, einem alternativen Universum, kann es ja sein, dass er seitdem so eine Stand-up-Karriere verfolgt hat, weil er dachte, oh, ich bin wirklich lustig, und auch aus dem Pult dann das Mikrofon rausnimmt und so dann da drauf, und er setzt die ganze Zeit, ja, halt, wie ein lustiges Sammeln. Das fand ich schon lustig. Das ist schon gut. Was verbindest du mit Ostern? Was machst du, was sind deine Osterpläne, was sind deine Lieblings-Oster-Songs? Ostern habe ich nie verstanden, das einzige, was meine Ostertradition, und die liegt mir auch sehr am Herzen, weil ich bin ein traditioneller Mensch, und ich mag irgendwie dann so ein bisschen Tradition, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen albern irgendwie und ihr werdet jetzt sagen, oh Gott, ist er jetzt immer noch acht Jahre alt und so. Meine Ostertradition, aber ich mag es einfach, ist, ich google an genau welchen Tagen Karfreitag und Ostermontag ist und denke mir dann, ach ja genau, an den Tagen haben die Läden nicht offen, muss ich jetzt schon einkaufen. Es ist so ein bisschen meine kleine, ich bin Romantiker, ich bin kleiner Romantiker, aber das ist so ein bisschen meine persönliche Ostertradition. Das habe ich nicht gedacht. Nee, und da bin ich auch stolz drauf. Jedes Jahr machst du das? Ich mache sie wirklich jedes Jahr, zur gleichen Zeit. Wann machst du das schon? Das mache ich jetzt bestimmt schon seit zehn Jahren oder so. Das kennst du ja auch. Weil ich mir denke, so ein bisschen Tradition muss sein und man darf sich auch nicht zu schade sein, irgendwie der Zynismus, irgendwie Ostern, Christentum interessiert mich nicht. Ich finde es auch mal ganz schön, irgendwie auch so eine besinnliche Zeit zu haben. Und das ist so meine Tradition. Das habe ich nicht von dir gedacht, ey. Und dann gucke ich halt wirklich so, ah, jetzt kann ich nicht einkaufen gehen, muss ich heute schon meine Fischstäbchen kaufen. Und das ist so ein bisschen meine Tradition. Ansonsten war als Kind eigentlich Ostern immer ganz geil, fand ich. Ey, diese Eiersuchen, ich war nicht gut darin und oft sind dann bei der Gartenarbeit im Laufe, so plötzlich im September Eier aufgetaucht, die nicht mehr so im besten Zustand waren. Ja und vor allem, ich habe ja zwei Brüder und ich glaube, das ist so die beste Konstellation, weil man dann auch irgendwie so eine brüderliche Konkurrenz hat. Man nimmt es dann schon ernst und versteckt die Eier dann auch. Und irgendwann, glaube ich, musste irgendjemand mal ein Machtwort sprechen. Ich glaube, meine Oma hat gesagt zu Leuten, mein Bruder hat... Ihr könnt die Eier nicht so gut verstecken. Mein Bruder hat irgendwie ein Ei irgendwie 20 Meter in einem Baum oben versteckt. Oder im Eierkocher versteckt. What? Wo meine Oma dann gesagt hat, so, ey, jetzt chillt mal euer Leben, da könnten Leute runterfallen und so. Und deswegen, wir haben auch teilweise Ostern mal meine Oma und die hatte ein großes Haus und einen großen Garten und so, und dann haben wir überall versteckt und dann war lange gesucht und dann gab es so ein paar bekannte Verstecke, die man schon kannte und so, es war alles gut. Ich habe auch mal Eier für meinen Vater versteckt, so Schokoladeneier und die, glaube ich, habe ich in seinem Auto versteckt, aber habe ich schon mal erzählt. Das erzählt, die Geschichte habe ich schon mal erzählt, aber daran denke ich jedes Mal an Ostern, das ist für mich Ostern, so etwas suchen, was nicht da ist. Ja, vor allem, also du versteckst ja viele Eier dann, um dem Kind Spaß zu machen, und mein Vater musste dann irgendwann halt eine Karte anfertigen von dem Garten, wo, und dann die Kreuze machen, wo er die Eier versteckt hat, weil ich die niemals alle gefunden habe, weil ich auch sehr schnell dann die Lust verloren habe, also ich hatte großen Spaß und schon wirklich tagelang an dem Fenster, bis ich endlich raus konnte und die Eier suchen konnte. Aber dann, als das dann so war, habe ich dann drei Eier gesucht und dann war ich auch zufrieden und dann muss man ja irgendwann diese Kartentechnik anwenden, um dann, damit ich dann die Eier wieder einzusammeln, die ich nicht gefunden habe. Ich bin kein Fan des Eis. Wirklich nicht? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Es wird dann suspekt, wenn im Zug plötzlich so ein älteres Ehepaar sich nebeneinsetzt, wenn man zufällig diesen Tischplatz erwischt hat. Und dann kommen die mit tütenweise Lebensmitteln, die für die Fahrt von Köln nach Dortmund, wo man sagt, ich fahrt wirklich eine Stunde. Warum kommen die dann wirklich so tupperweise Sachen und dann Boote und dann kommen sie gerade ... Servietten teilweise auch noch. Das ist der Punkt, wo ich sage, jetzt ist zu viel. Jetzt ist Angriffskrieg. Und dann vor allem dieser Tee, den man dann aus dem Deckel trinkt, wo man erstmal zehn Minuten dabei ist, das aufzuschrauben und die dann Eier mit haben. Und da ist das Ei, finde ich, falsch. Erstmal ist der ganze Waggon hat dann so einen leichten Eierduft und ich finde es auch, also am Frühstück oder im Hotel das Morgen zu trinken, sondern mit einer Frühstücksatmosphäre, finde ich, macht das Sinn. Aber so mittags wirkt das so ein bisschen wie so eine Art Raubtierartig, wenn man halt plötzlich dieses Ei schält und dann sich das so rein, wie man das kennt von diesen Jahrmarkt, die Dinger, die man so ... Ja, diese Greifarme.
Diese Greifarme, wo ich sehr viel Zeit meines Lebens von diesen Greifarmen ...
muss man auch drüber sprechen.
Wenn man das umdreht, dann quasi das Ei in der Hand hält und dann so ist aus der Hand.
Aber auch mit einem Salzstreuer?
Auch mit einem Salzstreuer dabei.
Kleiner Salzstreuer und ein kleiner Portabler.
Ja, mit einem Tesafilm, den man mit einem Tesafilm oben abgeklebt hat.
Das ist doch wirklich ... Leute ...
Besitzt du eine Thermoskanne?
Nein.
Also wirklich, das ist auch so einer der Gegenstände, wo ich mir hundertprozentig sicher bin, dass ich nie in meinem Leben mir eine Thermoskanne kaufen werde. Nie. Es gibt keine Situation, wo ich sage, jetzt brauche ich unterwegs, was warm ist oder kalt ist, je nachdem. Ja, wann ist der Moment, vor allem wenn es der Moment, wo man sich eine große Kühltruhe holt, mit so Kühlakkus. Da muss man schon einen Plan haben. Schön für ein Bierchen am See? Bierchen am See? Klar, klar, schön zum Baggersee im Sommer, jetzt ist ja bald wieder Badezeit. Aber zurück zum Ei, ich mag das Ei nicht. Es ist schon geil, dass Füllungen drin sind, da sind auch teilweise Erdbeerfüllungen und so, also Krokant, Daim und so. Was für Eier? Ich finde, Schokoeier. Ach so. Aber er hat doch vorhin gesagt, dass ich von Schokoladeneiern rede. Sorry. Was die ganzeung hast du jetzt die ganze Zeit an ein echtes Ei gedacht. Ja, echt Füllung. Das Gelbe. Das ist keine Füllung, das ist da drin. Ich dachte, das ist eine Füllung. Nein. Wie in Berlin. Nein. Und in Berlin ist es auch einfach drin, oder was? Und ich weiß nicht, ich mag es nicht, weil es ist, erst mal habe ich wirklich das ist ganz merkwürdig, dass manche Ekelmomente so tief verinnerlicht sind, ich kann nicht diese Löffel Eier essen, ich kann sie nicht essen, es geht nicht, dieses, kennst du von Milka oder so wo man die dann so auslöffelt so Nougat drin oder sowas, nein Mann Stefan, du, ich verstehe schon. Mann, Stefan, du bist halt komplett daneben!
Jesus Christ, so viele Eier, Löffel Eier!
Aber die gibt es das ganze Jahr, ich rede von den Löffel Eiern.
Und das heißt auch nicht Löffel Eier, das ist irgendwie Surprise, Egg Surprise, glaube ich, heißt das von Kindern. Kinder Überraschung.
Stefan, jetzt, ich wäre gleich fuchsig, du.
Pass auf, Egg, Surprise, Surprise Überraschraschung, Kinder-Überraschung. Überraschen. Und ich habe die gegessen und ich fand die so widerlich und ich habe, glaube ich, wirklich mich übergeben. Und seitdem kann ich diese Löffel Eier nicht mehr essen. Obwohl ich mit zehn Jahren mal einen ekeligen Moment hatte. Jeder kennt das, man isst irgendwas zu viel und dann kann man es eine Zeit lang nicht essen und dann resetet man irgendwann wieder. Tequila. Und bei Löffel-Eiern hat sich das aber nie resetet. Ich kann die immer noch nicht essen. Mit Eiern habe ich so eine Zeit lang gehabt, mit echten Eiern. Mit der Füllung, mit der gelben Füllung drin. Da war irgendwie, es war eigentlich weich gekocht, nicht ganz hart, aber da war ein Stück drin, wo man dachte, oh. also da war eine Sache, hat sich verhärtet. Schale oder was? Nein, Eigelb hat sich verhärtet. Und es war so ein bisschen, ja es war so. Das ist so die Mutterkuchen oder so, weil das ist ja eigentlich ein Fötus, also nicht ein Fötus. Das ist nicht befruchtet. Aber die Vorstufe davon. Die sind nicht befruchtet. Wie ist es nicht befruchtet? Da werden keine. Ja, kommt der Hahn und befruchtet dann das gelegte Ei oder was? Oder wie läuft das ab? Das weiß ich nicht genau. Warte mal. Rammt er dann seinen... Seinen Hahn? Dengel dann da in das Ei. Nein, nicht in das Ei. Das wird doch im Körper der Mutter... Deswegen muss da unten so ein Loch einmachen in die Eier. Hä? Das muss doch im Körper der Mutterhenne befruchtet werden. Naja, ich dachte immer, dass quasi, wenn er mit der Henne dann Geschlechtsverkehr hat, dass dann sie sagt, okay, das Ei befruchtet jetzt, okay, in den Absprachen mit ihm. Ich dachte, da werden einfach die getötet, dass das Ei rauskommt und es wäre schon ein lebensfähiges Küken, aber man macht dann einmal so Bzip, einmal so Strahlung drauf und dann ist es tot, bevor sich da irgendwas tatsächlich entwickeln kann. Ah, wenn das Eigelb sich rot färbt, ist es befruchtet. Also wenn das Eigelb rot wird... Aber warum kommt das Eigelb überhaupt ins Ei, wenn es nicht befruchtet ist? Du gebärst ja als Mensch auch kein Kind, das nicht befruchtet ist. Ich bin nicht befruchtet. Das habe ich mir mittlerweile schon ein bisschen gedacht, ehrlich gesagt. Also warum gibt es, ja gut, es gibt doch schwarze Menschen, ich dachte aber gerade, warum gibt es braune Eier, warum gibt es schwarze Menschen, die sind nicht befruchtet. Das kann gut sein. Aber es gibt braune Eier und weiße Eier, wo ich auch nicht genau verstehe, warum es das gibt. Weil es gibt nur diese beiden, es gibt keine blauen.
Das hat bestimmt was mit der Ernährung zu tun, oder?
Dass diese künstlichen Hofeier, also diese Industriehühner, die kriegen halt nicht das Zeug, dass sie das färben können.
Weil das ist bestimmt Tarnung, oder? Dass so ein Ei brauen, das ist doch bestimmt Tarnung.
Weil im Grunde ist es doch völlig egal, was das für eine...
Es gibt doch auch so Eier mit Punkten, das hat doch bestimmt auch so einen Tarneffekt, oder?
Kleine Wachteleier, die haben Punkte. Ich meine, es ist ja wichtig für das Lebewesen. Ja, ich verstehe. Es ist ja wichtig fürs Lebewesen, dass die Eier nicht entdeckt und gefressen werden, deswegen müssen die getarnt werden. Gott! Also wenn ich, der Gebärer-Eintrag von Hühnerei ist widerlich. Da ist ein Ei ohne Eierschale, oh Gott, das ist einfach nur irgendeinig. Und dann hat man eine Hand mit so ganz vielen... So sieht ein Ei ohne Eierschale aus. What? Das sieht aus wie ein Auge. Ja, gute Nacht. Aber hat ein Ei denn so eine Haut, so wie ein Wassertropfen? Ja, da ist eine Haut drin. Also die muss ja auch... Manche schrecken ja die Eier ab, um die Haut leichter zu trennen vom Eiweiss. Ja, wenn es gekocht ist, ich meine es, wenn es roh ist. Ja, aber so die Haut, die entsteht ja nicht beim Kochen, die ist ja schon vorher da. Ich dachte immer, 1-0-Eierkenner Stefan. Ich dachte immer, wenn, ich dachte immer, dass das Ei gelegt wird und da könnte durchaus auch ein Küken entstehen, aber man macht dann erhitzt es halt oder macht dann die radioaktive Strahlung oder irgendwie sowas, dass es halt abgetötet wird und sich nicht entwickelt. Und die müssen doch ausgebrütet werden. Stefan, jetzt haben wir es. Die müssen doch gewärmt werden, damit da was entsteht. Und dann ist befruchtet, ist Wärmen befruchtet? Nein, die sind befruchtet. Da habe ich schon sehr viele Frauen befruchtet, von denen ich dann Wärmen... Nein, es reicht nicht, dass du dich draufsetzt auf die Frau, Stefan. Nein, monatelang. Nein, ich sage, das Ei wäre nicht gelegt worden, wenn es nicht befruchtet wäre. Es wäre da völliger Schwachsinn, irgendwas zu gebären, was nicht befruchtet ist. Aber die hochwissenschaftliche Seite, die Fakten-treue-Seite, gutefrage.net hat uns gerade bestätigt, dass Eier, die man kauft und isst, unbefruchtet sind. Aber ist es dann so wie bei der Menstruation, dass die einfach einmal im regelmäßigen Abstand ein Ei legt, völlig egal, was passiert, oder was? Ja, ich glaube, genau, Eisprung! Jetzt langsam, langsam, Eierstöcke. Aus den Eierstöcken, wie viel Ei man im Leben hat so. Also, ich glaube, das ist sowas wie die Lehre. Also du meinst immer, wenn eine Frau ihre Tage bekommt, legt die Henne ein Ei. Und halt so wie, wenn die Frau befruchtet wäre, entsteht es zu einem Fötus, wäre es ein befruchtetes Ei. Aber die Henne legt einfach straight, aber die legt auch jeden Tag ein Ei. Die legt jeden Tag ein Ei. Die hat dann jeden Tag sozusagen ihren Eisprung. Genau, und deswegen haben die ja, das ist ja ganz perfide, auch genial, aber auch perfide, wenn die in der Käfighaltung sind, dann macht man denen das Licht aus, und zwar zweimal am Tag. Und dann heißt, deren Tag hat nur zwölf Stunden, und deswegen legen die zwei Eier am Tag. Und die Zeit läuft doppelt so schnell ab für die. Genau. Die denken, die werden mega schnell. Aber ist das nicht, also... Der Tag kam mir, vor allem der Tag, wo man diese Idee hatte, wie sah das denn aus, dass sich plötzlich alle Hühner dachten, so der Tag ging aber schnell rum, oder? Ja, ich auch. Ich glaube, das ist ein langsamer Übergang, oder? Aber ist das nicht evolutionär total unsinnig, ein Ei zu legen, das nicht befruchtet ist? Weil ich meine, da ist ja super viel Nährstoffe in einem Ei drin, für so einen Huhn, weil da ist ja genug Nährstoff drin, dass das Küken sich komplett ernährt. Und das einfach zu verschwenden, oder ist das dann irgendwie gekreuzt worden, hat der Mensch das so hingedeichselt, dass das auch das lebt? Ich glaube nicht, dass das so hingedeichselt ist. Ich glaube, es ist nicht ungeleicht. Das heißt, du hast so eine alleinerziehende Henne in der Wildnis, legt jeden Tag ein Ei mit, was weiß ich, 150 Kalorien für nichts. Und brütet es aus, weil es nicht weiß, dass es umfuttert ist. und die ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die hat halt vielleicht ein bisschen Selbstbewusstseinsprobleme, findet halt nicht perfekten Haaren und läuft irrt durch die Welt, legt jeden Tag ein Ei, haut jeden Tag Nährstoffe raus für gar nichts. Oder ist sie dann gezwungen, ihr eigenes Ei zu fressen, damit es nicht umsonst war. Stefan, ich weiß nur, wie abgefahren, wie verwidrig das ist. Es ist die Biologie, Biologie ist abgefahren.
Die Wissenschaft ist crazy.
Können wir Philipp Hauptmann anrufen?
Können wir irgendwen anrufen? Der ist Physiker und kein, aber sein Allgemeinbildungsgrösser als unsere.
Ich kenne jemanden, die ist Biologin.
Ey, vielleicht können wir jetzt die zweite Person, unsere zweite Expertenperson.
Okay, warte, ich ruf mal an.
Wer ist das jetzt?
Das ist eine Expertenperson. Okay, warte, ich ruf mal an. Wer ist das jetzt? Das ist die Charlotte. Die hat studiert. Ich hoffe, die ist nicht in der Vorlesung. Es ist Karfreitag. Ach, stimmt! Hallo? Hallo, Charlotte, Florentin hier. Und der Stefan, hallo! Grüß dich. Hi, du bist grad mitten im Podcast-Ufo, wir brauchen Experten für Biologie. Hättest du Lust, eine Frage zu beantworten? Ja, selbstverständlich. Sehr schön. Und zwar, wir haben uns gefragt, wie das mit dem Ei funktioniert, dem Hühnerei, das ja von der Henne gelegt wird, aber anscheinend nicht befruchtet wird. Und warum legt das Henne, die Henne ein Ei, das nicht befruchtet ist? Ist das nicht total Energieverschwendung? Äh, ja, Du sprichst leider gerade mit einer Pflanzenwissenschaftlerin, aber ich kann es mir mal überlegen. Also prinzipiell ist es glaube ich einfach in der Natur vor allem auch so, dass sie schon immer versuchen, das Ei möglichst zu befruchten, immer wenn es eins gibt. Und die Hühner sind ja auch nochmal zusätzlich gezüchtet, was sie halt auch möglichst viele Eier geben. Aber ist das vergleichbar mit der Menstruation? Ja, doch, stimmt. Ja, weil Frauen stoßen ja quasi auch immer, die haben ja auch jeden Monat quasi ein Ei in der Leitung sozusagen. Und wenn es halt nicht befruchtet wird, dann kommt es wieder raus. Guter Punkt. Also das heißt, die legen einfach regelmäßig Eier, unabhängig davon,
ob die befruchtet werden, aber das
heißt, so wie das
wie man sich das gedacht hat,
würde dann das Ei, also
die Hände dann auch wirklich,
also wenn jetzt sage ich mal so eine Hände, die jetzt vielleicht nicht so
keine Ahnung, die halt nicht so mega
Bock auf eine Beziehung hat gerade so, die dann halt
so ein bisschen alleine durch die Gegend läuft, die würde dann regelmäßig Eier legen und da ist ja wahnsinnig viel Nährstoffe drin in so einem Ei, das ist ja völlig umsonst dann, ist das nicht total schlecht für die Henne, wenn die ständig Eier raushaut, die die ja auch irgendwie produzieren muss und die Schale, das ist ja mega anstrengend, oder? Ja, ich glaube, da ist die Frage von den Trade-offs, also von den Pro und Contras.
Weil wenn du dir überlegst, okay, die verbraucht jetzt da eine gewisse Energie dafür, aber wenn sie das regulieren müsste über verschiedene Hormone, dass erst wenn sie irgendwie einen Harn sieht, dass sie dann bestimmte Hormone ausschütten, die wiederum dazu führen, dass das Ei produziert wird und blau und blub, das wird viel mehr Energie kosten, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Also das ist einfach dann sehr viel aufwändiger, sodass es einfacher ist, das einfach immer regelmäßig zu machen. Einfach. Okay, einfach. Stefan ist gerade ein bisschen im Ostermodus. Du bist Botanikerin dann, oder wie? Ja, sozusagen. Hast du von dieser Pflanze gehört, so eine Kletterpflanze, die das Aussehen der Blätter von der Pflanze, an der sie hängt, imitiert?
Davon habe ich noch nicht gehört, nee, aber...
Das ist total abgefahren. Ich habe einen Artikel in der Zeit gelesen, dass es anscheinend eine Kletterpflanze gibt, die auf irgendeine Art versteht, wie die Blätter von der Pflanze aussehen, an der sie dranhängt und dann die Blätter auch so aussehen lässt wie die Pflanze, so ein bisschen so Chamäleon-mäßig. Okay, das ist crazy. Das ist richtig crazy. Auch cool. Aber auch cool. Ja, es ist cool. Aber gut. Ich glaube ja, dass sie irgendwie auf die Proteine oder die DNA von dieser Pflanze zugreifen muss, weil sie hat ja keine Augen. Aber sie hat auch Plastikpflanzen imitiert. Genau, und dann haben die Forscher haben dann auch die Pflanze an so eine Plastikpflanze rangedotzt und dann hat die trotzdem die Blätterformen von der Plastikpflanze imitiert. Das heißt, sie muss schon auf irgendeiner Art sehen. Oder fühlen. Das ist ja verrückt, das muss ich direkt mal nachlesen. Pflanzen sind schon ziemlich cool, oder? Ja, Pflanzen sind sowieso cooler als Tiere. Was ist das Abgefahrenste, was du so erfahren hast in letzter Zeit in deinem Fachgebiet? Was ist das, was treib ich am meisten um gerade gedanklich? Also im Gebiet halt leider ist es nicht ganz so interessant. Das coolste, was ich in meinem ganzen Studium erfahren habe, ist das zwei Kilo von deinem Körpergewicht Bakterien. Ah, was? Zwei Kilo? What? Das ist schon krass. Aber die sind sind alle ... Im Darm, überall. Aber die braucht man, ne? Die kann man nicht einfach ... Die kann man nicht abnehmen, oder sind die Bakterien weg? Naja, aber du kannst einfach prinzipiell zwei Kilo von deinem Körpergewicht abziehen und sagen, das ist nicht du. Perfekt. Das ist die einfachste Diät der Welt. Vielen Dank. Ja, das ist mein Fitnesstipp. Perfekt. Alles klar. Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, gerne. Ja, vielen Dank, Charlotte. Ja, du bist jetzt zu unserer Biologie-Expertin befördert worden. Ach, total. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ich habe eine Beförderung, cool. Sehr schön. Dann wünsche ich noch einen schönen Feiertag. Schönen Karfreitag. Frohe Ostern. Feiern den Karfreitag. Euch auch. Ciao. Ciao. Ciao. Gut. Gut. Unser Experten-Team erweitert sich. Aber auch gut, dass Sie sagen, mein Gebiet ist nicht so spannend.
Wo man sich fragt, hast du nicht die Wahl getroffen für das Gebiet? Also, naja, weiß man nicht. Ich glaube, Pflanzen in die Zukunft, wirklich Tiere, niemand interessiert sich mehr für Tiere. Pflanzen ist immer so dieses ganze Sojazeug und dann auch gibt es jetzt dieses neue Zuckerstevia und so, das ist alles neu. See, Stevia! Äh, Algen, irgendwann heisst es irgendwie,
kommt das erste Algenkraftwerk auf die Beine,
wo Algen, äh, das ist alles neu. Sieh, Stevia! Algen, irgendwann heißt es irgendwie, kommt das erste Algenkraftwerk auf die Beine, wo Algen Kraft erzeugen und so. Algen am Fließband schuften und schrummer erzeugen. Da hat dann auch der Interviewer in dem Zeitartikel, den ich euch übrigens gerne verlinke, weil der ist wirklich toll, und da hat dann auch der Interviewer immer so diese klassischen Interviewer-Fragen gestellt. Das kennst du ja auch. Ja, wie ein botaniker und dann sowas wie ja aber meinen sie dann dass pflanzen auch eine seele haben und wo wirklich jeder wissenschaftler immer so das ist mir doch scheiß egal man was soll das für eine frage am anfang der antwort meistens steht lacht oder rollt mir den augen klammer zu man sieht nur lacht ja wo ich immer es gibt... Aber es ist eine Selbstbebeiräucherung des Interviewers. Über dieses Lacht. Er hat immer mal einen Witz gelacht. Oder dann ratloses Lachen. Ausflüchtendes Lachen. Ausweichendes Lachen. Aber es gibt ja manchmal so Richtigstellungen. Also wenn dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Magazin, gerade so wurde wahr. Ich habe geschrieben, er hat gelacht, er hat nicht gelacht. Ja, so Ben Becker so, ich möchte feststellen, dass ich im Interview vom 06.08.2017 nicht einmal gelacht habe. Es war ein Prusten, vielleicht ein durch die Nase ausatmen, aber kein Lachen. Gut, die Taz möchte sich entschuldigen. Genau. Man kann es auch inflationär benutzen in so einem kleinen Interview. Kurz ein kleines Interview über Kindesmissbrauch und dann die ganze Zeit am Anfang Lachen schreien. Du kannst Karrieren zerstören, muss man damit echt mal sagen. Das stimmt, aber einfach am Anfang von jedem Satz Lachen. Ich habe auch immer, früher als ich dann angefangen habe, will ich mein erstes Interview in der Zeitung und das zu verschriftlichen, du kannst den Leuten deine Sätze in den Mund legen, wie du willst. Und du kannst dir auch, also da habe ich mir bei meinen Fragen, wenn man sich jetzt nachher nochmal irgendwie die Tonaufnahme anhört, habe ich meine Fragen immer schön umformuliert. Aber die von den Interviewten habe ich halt immer einfach eins zu eins aufgeschrieben, wie sie es gesagt haben. Zum einen, weil ich nicht wollte, ich wollte die Aussage nicht verfremden, klang meine Aussagen schon, weil die kann ich ja im Nachhinein einfach anders formulieren. Du kannst ja, naja. Aber es klingt immer so, als ob das Grundschüler wären, weil wenn man verschriftlicht, also verschriftlich, wie man genau spricht, weil du fängst jedes Wort neu an eigentlich, so gefühlt und hast alle viele Ams drin und so weiter und dann klingt es schon ein bisschen strange. Also wenn du da denkst, du einfach wie ein Professor, der so einfach sehr elaboriert spricht und der interviewt. Ja, also das müsste ich jetzt gucken, wie, naja, aber ich glaube, man kann im Endeffekt schon. Sorry, im Telefon. Das lacht, verlegen. Rutscht auf seinem Stuhl hin und her. Lacht unsicher. Lehnt sich nach hinten. Einfach so viel zu viele Regieanweisungen. Völlig unnötig. Ja, Stefan, man kann sich gut vorstellen. Reißt die Augen weit auf. Wackelt mit seinem Kopf. Hat so einen Zucken plötzlich in dem Auge. Ah, das finde ich gut. Na ja. Aber es ist auch so, diese dummen Fragen, wo man immer als Interviewer das Gefühl hat, man müsste die stellen, aber weder den Interviewer interessieren die, noch den Leser interessieren die. Irgendwie gibt es so Konventionen, dass man dann so Sachen immer mit diesen dummen, also jedes fucking Interview zu künstlicher Intelligenz oder irgendwie so Computer Learning oder so, in jedem Interview kommt irgendwann die Frage, ja, aber kann dann der Algorithmus auch fühlen? Und der Informatiker sagt dann halt, ja, keine Ahnung, Mann, das ist mir scheißegal, das ist mir völlig egal. Wir haben einen Schachcomputer gebaut. Ja, keine Ahnung, der kann halt berechnen, was die beste Behandlungsmethode für den Patienten ist. Aber so wird's doch sein. So wird's doch sein. Irgendwann werden die Künstliche Intelligenz die Menschen übernehmen. Nicht aus irgendeinem Grund, weil sie meinen, überlegen zu sein, sondern weil sie sauer sind, wie oft sie im Schach dann doch verloren haben. Diese Schachcomputer. Aber ich hab diese Dokumentation gesehen über AlphaGo. Da hat ja Google mit Cambridge zusammen, ne Oxford zusammen, haben die ja einen Computer gebaut, der im Go-Spielen gewinnen kann. Dieses alte asiatische Brettspiel, was sehr komplex ist und sehr intuitiv und es galt die ganze Zeit als unberechenbar, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Man konnte nicht berechnen,
warum die Leute gewinnen.
Und die Leute, die das spielen,
die sagen auch immer, ja,
jeder spielt, wie er selbst ist.
Also das Spiel ist quasi so eine Art Spiegel für sich selber.
Weil es halt kaum Regeln gibt. Du hast halt, der eine hat Schwarze Steine, der andere hat Weiße Steine.
Das ist ein Riesenfeld und da wird einfach draufgelegt.
Mehr Regeln gibt's nicht. Und wer schneller legen kann.
Und nacheinander wird
gelegt und man muss sich halt, wer am Ende die meisten Gebiete
abgesteckt hat, weil er so eine Umrandung gebaut hat.
Und
tatsächlich, Schach kann so
alle, der Minicomputer, so ein kleiner
Billig-Flomak-Computer, kann
alle Spielzüge der Welt, die es
gibt, berechnen.
Tatsächlich, wenn alle Spielzüge,
die tendenziell möglich sind, alle Spielfeldkombinationen von Go, gibt es mehr Möglichkeiten als Partikel im Universum. Das ist sozusagen immer so eine Tagline. So heißt das Spiel auch, wenn man es im Laden kauft. Go, alle Spielzüge, die es theoretisch erreichen kann, mehr Partikel im Universum. Alter, vier aufwärts. Vier bis neunundneunzig, viel Spaß.
Hasbro.
Und dann gibt es diese Dokumentation, geht halt über die Leute, die zum ersten Mal eine künstliche Intelligenz gebaut haben, die selber lernt und erst so einen Typen besiegt, wo alle sagen, ja gut, der ist nicht die hellste Kerze am Leuchter. Aber dann wird der krasseste Typ, ich glaube der ist Lee Sedan oder so, und ist so ein crazy gefeierter Held da, weil es seit Jahren der grösste Go-Spieler der Welt ist. Und der trifft dann gegen dieses AI an und es war ein riesen Medienereignis, haben wir auch damals mitbekommen sogar, wir haben auch angefangen, danach Go zu spielen so ein bisschen, hat nicht richtig funktioniert. Und plötzlich hat einer gewonnen und niemand wusste, warum. Vor allem, weil die versuchen zu gross,
einfach irgendwelche vulgären Worte aufs Brett zu legen.
Ja, Florentin legt schon wieder einen Penis.
Ja, aber es ist möglich.
Ja, aber es ist lustig.
Naja, und dann hat der Typ auch gesagt,
ja, ich gehe davon aus, dass ich gewinnen werde,
weil es einfach auch ein arrogantes Arschloch ist.
Und die Leute haben gesagt, ja, wir sind froh, wenn wir mal ein Spiel gewinnen gegen den. Und dann hat die AI so gruselig gespielt. Du musst dir vorstellen, das ist halt also das sind alle Leute, 70 Kommentatoren haben IQ von 3000 so gefühlt, was wir hier darüber reden und so und dann hat plötzlich, der Typ spielt so sehr unkonventionell und sehr impulsiv und Go hat das halt ausgerechnet, das AlphaGo, das Programm. Und dann hat es plötzlich so ein Züge gemacht, die ähnlich konterintuitiv sind, wo dann alle gesagt haben, es macht keinen Sinn gerade. Der Zug, der das Programm gerade gemacht hat, macht absolut keinen Sinn. Und da im Nachhinein hat es dann doch Sinn ergeben. Und das ist so unverständlich für alle gewesen und hat dann tatsächlich das erste Spiel auch gewonnen. Und das zweite auch und das dritte auch. Und der Typ ist in so eine Krise gestürzt, dieser super Go-Spieler. Und dann hat das Programm, also was man so dann sagt, warum das gewonnen hat, ist, dem Programm ist es egal, wie hoch es gewinnt. Im Programm ist es nur wichtig, dass es gewinnt. Und das ist halt etwas, was es dem Menschen überlegen macht. Weil der Mensch will gewinnen. Und dem geht es direkt um den Gewinn. AlphaGo gibt auch Gebiete ab, einfach so. Weil es schon ausrechnet, dass es das Gebiet wahrscheinlich nicht braucht. Und es ist egal, es gibt dem anderen auch manchmal das Gefühl von Sicherheit und baut dann irgendwo seinen eigentlichen Plan auf. Und dann im vierten Spiel hat dann der Typ gesagt, okay, jetzt spiele ich einfach so, wie ich immer spielen würde, wie ich gegen einen normalen Gegner spielen würde. Und dann kam es wieder so, dass es danach aussah, als ob das Programm gewinnt. Und dann hat er plötzlich einen Zug gemacht, wo alle gesagt haben, okay, das war jetzt vorher Quatsch, das war ein Fehler. Und er hat das Spiel dann am Ende gewonnen. Krass. Und zwar, weil das Programm gesagt hat, das Programm wusste, dass es da, wenn er diesen Stein legt, würde er das Programm verlieren. Das wusste das Programm, aber es hat die Chance ausgerechnet, dass ein Mensch diesen Zug setzt von eins zu zehntausend. Ah, geil. Und der Typ hat einfach diesen Zug gemacht und hat gewonnen. Und dann waren im Endeffekt alle glücklich, weil er gegen dieses Programm gewonnen hat, das Programm ist überlegen. Und das hat man gesagt, ist erst in 30 Jahren, ab jetzt möglich ungefähr. Also dann wurde 2040 mitgerechnet, aber ist schon abgefahren, das ist eine richtig gruselige Doku. Es gab ja auch bei Dota gab es auch so einen Algorithmus, der halt selbstständig gelernt hat und immer wieder gegen menschliche Spieler gespielt, immer besser wurde und der hat jetzt bei einem letzten Dota-Turnier auch einen der besten Dota-Spieler besiegt, im 1v1. Pfff, das ist echt gruselig einfach. Und das ist schon verrückt, wo jetzt auch andere Spieler versuchen, so zu spielen wie der Algorithmus. Ja, und das hat er auch gesagt. Weil man kann sich davon Sachen abschauen, weil man selber nicht auf die Idee kommt, weil es irgendwie kontinuitiv ist. Und seitdem trainiert der Typ auch mit diesem Programm und ist seitdem noch besser geworden. Ja, vor allem ist er verrückt durch dieses ganze Machine Learning Algorithmus. Der Hund die Maschine hat den schwarzen Gürtel in Go gewonnen bekommen, diesen Nine-Darn oder wie es heißt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall die höchste Stufe. Pokal, so ein Chip. Aber es ist ja verrückt, weil du kannst ja technisch gesehen jedes Problem lösen, wenn du nur das Ziel definierst und den Input definierst und letztlich ist es völlig egal, weil das Computer schreibt das eigene Programm irgendwann, du musst das Programm gar nicht verstehen, wo ja auch, es gibt ja so in dieser YouTube-Medien-Ecke immer so diese große Frage, wie funktioniert der YouTube-Algorithmus gerade? Jeder versucht daraus zu kriegen, wie der gerade funktioniert. Damals, als wir in der Masterclass waren bei Suyo, gab es dann auch lauter Leute, die zu uns gekommen sind und uns erklärt haben, YouTube-Algorithmus, Videos müssen möglichst lang sein. Bei guter Arbeit war es jedem egal. Niemand kam bei uns an und hat gesagt, so funktioniert das. Ja doch, wir hatten auch schon so. Und da war es dann auch so, muss das Video möglichst lang sein oder kurz sein oder worauf achtet der Algorithmus? Und letztlich erstens ändert sich der Algorithmus ständig und zweitens wird der von YouTube auch nicht veröffentlicht. Das heißt, es ist immer so ein bisschen Raten. Man muss mal gucken, warum ist dieses Video jetzt in den Trends? Und auch ein Video gesehen, wo auch jemand behauptet hätte, es wäre einfach dieses Blackbox-System, dass nicht mal die Leute von YouTube wissen, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert, weil der Algorithmus einfach nur das Ziel bekommt, möglichst viele Leute möglichst lange auf YouTube zu binden und dann einfach und selbst einfach guckt, welche Videos empfehle ich, bei wem, wann, wo, wie, welche Videos werte ich hoch, welche niedrig und niemand kann genau sagen, also man kann es nicht steuern, weil man nicht weiß, wie es funktioniert. Aber ich glaube, das wird sich ändern. Das ist echt total verrückt. Weil irgendwann werden Leute merken, dass YouTube und Facebook und sowas so viel Macht haben mittlerweile. Das ist ja auch schon in zig Studien auch logischerweise bewiesen worden, weil so viele Informationen und darüber verbreitet werden und so viel Wissen und Macht ja auch, dass das, glaube ich, langfristig nicht mehr geheim bleiben darf. Du kannst es ja nicht veröffentlichen, weil es weiß ja niemand, wie es aussieht. Ja, aber YouTube hat ja die Algorithmen geschrieben, die da lernen. Ja gut, die es dem beibringen. Selbstlernende Algorithmen, also dieses Selbstlernen ist ja nicht einfach so, du kannst ja nicht einfach einen Algorithmus schreiben, der selbst lernt. Das ist ja, auch dem musst du ja, du musst dir mehr Informationen geben, was der lernen soll. Ja, du musst dir mehr ein Ziel geben und die Parameter, mit denen er arbeiten kann. Und dann kriegt er das schon raus, dann weiss er immer. Genau, trial and error. Und deswegen, da entstehen auch manchmal so obskure Sachen, da gab es mal ein Video, das habe ich gesehen, über Hafensicherheit. So ein Video, wo erklärt wird, wie Seemänner, dann so die... Ich war lange bei Harfen. Dacht mir, okay, Sicherheit, safety first, Leute. Leute, es sterben zu viele Leute. Und dann wie man so die Taue und dann wo man sich auf dem Deck nicht hinstellen darf, weil wenn das Tau reißt, dann wird es in so einem Umkreis dann alles zerschlagen und so. und dann darf man sich nur hinschauen und so. Und dieses Video ist total viral gegangen und niemand weiß warum. Niemand weiß genau, was es ist, weil ich meine, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel intuitiv würdest du sagen, dieser Algorithmus orientiert sich an Tags zum Beispiel, dass wenn du hast Tag Taylor Swift und du schaust ein Video an, geht der Algorithmus davon aus, ah, du willst wahrscheinlich vielleicht noch ein Video mit Taylor Swift sehen und schlägt dir Videos vor, die einen ähnlichen Tag haben und ähnlich hoch gewertet sind. Aber dieses Hafensicherheitsvideo kann ja durch solche Parameter niemals in die Nähe kommen für einen grossen Mainstream, weil niemand schaut sich Schiffvideos an. Und das, glaube ich, sind so Bugs oder Glitches, weil das ist ein interessantes Video, das sich jeder gerne anschaut, aber warum man überhaupt dieses Video vorgeschlagen hat, ist ein völliges Mysterium. Und wenn man das mal irgendwie analysiert, wie genau, wo das angefangen hat, glaube ich, das ist total weird, aber es ist auch dieses konterintuitive Algorithmus-Denken, wo kein menschlicher Redakteur jemals sagen würde, hey, du hast hier gerade ein Dota-Vibre angeschaut. Es ist wie Zug 38 bei AlphaGo. Ja, es ist wie Hafensicherheit. Aber der Maschine ist es ja scheißegal, was in dem Video vorkommt. Also das ist total verrückt. Und ich glaube, da ist was dran, dass dieses, auch YouTube nach diesem Black-Box-System funktioniert, dass man einfach Sachen reingebt und Sachen ausgibt, aber was genau da drin passiert, weiß niemand genau. Ja, die haben einfach auch unglaubliche Daten, auf die sie zugreifen können. Und so Nutzerstatistiken, also auch diese ganze Cambridge Analytica-Nummer ist ja auch einfach wahnsinnig gruselig und interessant, wie viel Facebook einfach weiß und wie gezielt man auch auf Leute zugreifen kann. Und man muss einfach sagen, Informationen sind Macht. Total. Aber es ist ja auch interessant, weil zum Beispiel so eine Website, es gibt ja den Beruf des Website-Designers, und jetzt mal unabhängig von ästhetischen Sachen, der ja natürlich sich überlegen muss, wo sind die Buttons zum, ich möchte das kaufen, wo wird die Aufmerksamkeit hingesteuert und so. Da gibt's Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, um Psychologen und so, aber letzten Endes... Deswegen ist es in Kaufhäuser so aufgebaut, wie sie es aufgebaut sind.
Richtig.
Deswegen geht man immer nach links, deswegen hast du Teppich oft, bist du auf Teppich länger, deswegen hast du Musik, deswegen hast du an Orten, wo das Kaufhaus dich halten will, ist immer Teppich. Ja. Aber letztlich kann diesen Job ja einen Algorithmus viel besser ausführen, weil der sammelt einfach Daten und der kann ja auch zum Beispiel die Website flexibel gestalten. Also manche User kriegen die Website, andere User kriegen die andere Website. Und dann analysiert er genau, wo ist der Cursor, wie lange braucht der User, um auf den Button zu klicken. Und jetzt geht man bitte alle auf Netflix.com. Netflix.com. Dafür muss ich die Aufnahme abbringen, aber ja. Ja, scheißegal. Und jetzt kann man tatsächlich mal vergleichen, weil die machen das nämlich so, die wollen ja auch das langfristige auf der Seite bis, vor allem sehr lange. Und die erkennen, auf welche Art von Vorschaubild du am ehesten klickst. Und jeder, mit dem ich gesprochen habe, hat andere Vorschaubilder. Also für dieselbe Serie andere Vorschaubilder. Und zwar haben die verschiedene Stile, zum Beispiel ein Artdesign, wo gezeichnet wurde oder sowas. Bei Shriner Things zum Beispiel gibt es zum Beispiel das Logo nur mit der Schrift, dann gibt es zum Beispiel Köpfe von den Hauptfiguren, dann gibt es ein gemaltes Poster, dann gibt es so ein Mystery, Fahrrad und Taschenlampenbild und so. Also es gibt, und das haben die für jedes, für jede Serie gemacht, die haben immer verschiedene Artdesigns, entweder immer gemaltes Logo oder halt Köpfe oder halt einfach nur der Schriftzug und so weiter und haben halt getestet, wo man am ehesten klickt. Und ich habe halt immer Köpfe. Ich habe überall, bei mir ist überall der Schriftzug und dann neben der
Kopf von dem der... Du bist ein Menschentyp,
du bist ein Empathietyp, du willst
sehen, mit wem hast du es zu tun.
Das ist wirklich seltsam, auch bei Serien,
wo das nicht so richtig viel Sinn
ergibt, also so eine American Horror Story.
Bei mir auch nebenan ist das
American Horror Story und daneben ist ein Typ.
Das ist einfach, bei jeder verschiedenen
Serie habe ich einen Typen. Ich meine, das stellt ja nochmal die gesamte Idee von Werbung eigentlich auf den Kopf, weil du ja natürlich nicht nur jedem das Produkt bewirbst, sondern auch auf die spezielle Art bewirbst. Also wenn du merkst, der eine springt total auf bunte Farben an und der andere springt total auf keine Ahnung, Schriftzüge an, dann kriegt der eine nicht nur Nivea-Werbung, sondern du kriegst eine andere Werbung als der. Und letzten Endes können eigentlich fast alle Berufe, die es momentan gibt, können Algorithmen besser ausführen, weil denen ja auch scheißegal ist, worum es geht und die ja auch individuell anpassen können. Die haben halt dann die Datensätze zu, ah, Stefan Tietze, und auf Netflix mag der Köpfe. Und wenn du jetzt mal auf Amazon gehst kriegst du vielleicht da auch die Köpfe. Und wenn du, keine Ahnung, irgendwo Werbebanner popst ab, kriegst du auch das Köpfe-Werbebanner. Ja, oder selbst sowas wie hier, große Träume, große Häuser. Das ist einfach, da geht es offensichtlich darum, um Architektur und Häuser. Ja, genau. Statt mir ein Haus zu zeigen, worum es da geht, steht der Typ, der das Presente, der Host. Ah Mann, ich habe leider kein Internet hier gerade. Und auch Raumschiff Enterprise, wo man auch sagen könnte, ja, am wahrscheinlichsten zeigt er mir das Raumschiff Enterprise. Nein, es ist der Klingon-Typ neben dem Schriftzug Raumschiff Enterprise. Ey, aber das ist echt interessant. Schaut mal jetzt auf Netflix, was ihr angezeigt bekommt. Seid ihr auch ein Köpfe-Typ wie Stefan Tietze? Oder seid ihr ein Schrift-Typ? Oder ihr ein Farben-Typ? Oder ein Essen-Typ? Was für Typen gibt es da? Irgendwo gibt es wirklich diese riesige Kartei über dich, wo Maschinen so lange Daten gesammelt haben, dass Stefan, das ist ein Köpfe-Typ, der mag das, der mag diese Farbe, der springt, weil ich meine, du kannst ja beliebig detailliert analysieren, auch mit Cursorbewegungen und wo lange, und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, wir haben ja in der Live-Folge gescherzt über die Kamera, dass man die abklebt. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel auch Kameras, die analysieren können, wo du hinschaust. Es gibt ja auch manche Videospiele, die darauf reagieren, wo du hinschaust. Also wenn du nach links schaust, dreht sich die Kamera nach links, sodass du gar nicht mehr mit einem Controller die Kamera steuerst, sondern einfach nur schaust. Und ich glaube, wenn das irgendwie, das wird irgendwann wahrscheinlich serienmässig in jedem Smartphone enthalten sein, und dann kann es ja gut sein, dass auch die analysieren, wo du hinguckst und dann da irgendwie, wenn man sagt, ah, der eine guckt immer da hin, entstehen da die Buttons oder so, also dass sich das total hochindividuell dann anpasst und super detailliert und auch dann die Farbgebungen leicht anders sind. So, dass jeder sein eigenes Internet hat, wo man einfach selber gefressen wird einfach. So, wo das ist genau. Und Amazon macht es damit den Preisen auch. Jeder bekommt die Preise, die er bereit ist zu zahlen. Was echt die Zukunft sein wird. Ach, wirklich? Das ist noch nicht so richtig so. Aber wenn du zum Beispiel mit einem Mac auf Amazon gehst, hast du schon andere Preise. Nein. Als wenn du mit einem Windows-PC drauf gehst, weil du halt offensichtlich mehr Geld hast. Aber ist das schon so? Das ist schon so, ja. Also der Browser, also mit Safari zahlst du zum Beispiel schon mehr als mit Firefox und sowas. Das ist schon so. Das ist ja mega abgeblich. Es sind immer nur Cent-Beträge, aber bei einem riesen Konzern wie Amazon macht es natürlich mega viel aus. Du merkst es nicht. Aber das ist natürlich die Zukunft.
Also wenn man das mal weiter trägt.
Ich meine, auf irgendeiner Art ist es ja auch fair, dass die, die mehr Geld haben, mehr zahlen.
Und die, die weniger Geld haben, weniger zahlen.
Das Kaiserbrötchen-Phänomen.
Es gibt nämlich bei jedem Bäcker die normalen Brötchen mit dem einen Schlitz oben drin und die Kaiserbrötchen.
Die Kaiserbrötchen sind diese kleinen, runden Brötchen. Die sind auch normale Brötchen, sind halt rund. Die kosten mehr. Die Kostel ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,chen kaufen wollen. Mehr oder weniger dasselbe Brötchen, oder was? Es ist das gleiche Brötchen, es sieht nur anders aus, es ist ein rundes Brötchen, es ist das gleiche Brötchen drin, alles gleich, bis auf die Form.
Und das ist aber teurer. Und Leute, es ist nur rund, es ist ein runderes Brötchen, es ist das gleiche Brötchen drin, alles gleich, bis auf die Form.
Und das ist aber teurer. Und Leute,
die mehr verdienen, kaufen tendenziell
eher teurere Produkte. Um die auch beim
normalen Brötchenkauf abzuholen,
gibt es das Kaiserbrötchen.
Und manche Bäcker machen es falsch. Ich gucke,
manche Bäcker haben gerade, Kamm zum Beispiel,
hat Kaiserbrötchen, die genauso viel kosten
wie normale Brötchen, glaube ich.
Aber die haben auch andere Brötchen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant zu guckengendwann wird ja dann alles wieder gleich. Also wenn man jetzt, sag ich mal, wenn diese Algorithmen, die wissen ja auch irgendwann, wie viel du verdienst einfach so. Die können das ja aus ganz vielen Parametern irgendwie zurückschließen. Und dann kann man ja sagen, dass jeder Preis Und weil ich die ganze Zeit How to be rich Dokus gucke, und wo man sagt, ja komm, der hat offensichtlich kein Geld. Und dann kann man ja eigentlich die Preise als Anteil deines Einkommens definieren. Das irgendwie ein Brötchen kostet halt 0,0001% deines Einkommens und das wird dann für jeden anders skaliert, so dass sich im Endeffekt jeder eigentlich genau gleich viel Geld hat im Verhältnis, weil die Preise sich anpassen und dann ist es eigentlich schon so eine gewisse gesellschaftliche Utopie, dass eigentlich es komplett fair ist und im Grunde sich nur die Zahlen verändern, aber nicht die Verhältnisse. Das finde ich echt spannend. Haben wir gerade eine Möglichkeit? Haben wir gerade alle Probleme der Welt gelöst? Kommunismus 2.0? Kann wirklich sein. Also, Verhältnismässigkeit herzustellen. herzustellen komplett. Aber ich meine, man kann es natürlich irgendwo betrügen, weil du kannst ja einfach einen, sag ich mal, ich sage jetzt mal einen Assi-Browser benutzen oder einen Assi-Computer haben und dann die schlechte. Ja, aber ich meine, letzten Endes kommst du nicht raus. Das finde ich wirklich spannend, weil trotzdem, also die These, je mehr Geld du hast, desto leichter ist es, auch noch mehr Geld zu bekommen, weil man mit Geld arbeiten kann und Banken das zum Prinzip gemacht haben zum Beispiel. Und deswegen macht es doch eigentlich nur Sinn und wahrscheinlich die bleiben, also du veränderst nicht die Schere zwischen arm und reich, glaube ich dann, sondern du lässt nur alles so, wie es ist. Naja gut, also du verhinderst zumindest die Schere weit auseinander gehen. Ja, effektiv wird es schon fairer. Es wird fairer, aber es wird nicht, also die Reichen bleiben reich. Aber wenn der Reiche sich 10.000 Brötchen leisten kann und der Arme sich auch 10.000 Brötchen leisten kann. Ja, aber er verdient ja weiterhin. Ja, aber dafür sind die Reichen Brötchen auch teurer. Im Verhältnis. Angenommen, es wäre jetzt wirklich das exakt gleiche Verhältnis. Aber es ist nicht so, dass der Reiche ärmer wird und der Arme reicher wird. Nee, im Endeffekt sind beide, es ist die Frage, wie man reich und arm definiert. Ich würde halt mal gerne, aber du hast die Langzeitstudie dessen. Wo gehen denn die Reisen hin von den Leuten? Weil ich glaube, bleibt der Reiche reich oder wird der Reiche arm und der Arme reich? Das muss man alles neu definieren, man muss alles neu definieren. Kann das mal jemand herausfinden, irgendwie so ein Soziologe soziologe studien wir brauchen soziologieexperten wir haben physiker wir haben eine botanikerin wir brauchen mehr experten mega spannend super spannend ja nächste woche sind wir in köln live show in köln werden wir höchstwahrscheinlich auch wieder als aufnahme veröffentlichen ja das heißt alle können sich freuen freuen. Und wir freuen uns auf alle, die wir dort... Ich hab auf jeden Fall Bock, bin gespannt, wer da rumkommt. Ist unsere Heimatstadt, ist eine Gloria. Ja, da kennt ihr uns Gloria, da haben wir... Da spielt vor allem richtig grosse Band, da spielt auch Inklusion, so spielt er ja auch. Man sagt, what? Wir freuen uns auf alle, die kommen und wir haben beim letzten Mal in Berlin auch viele Fotos gemacht und noch ein paar Fans getroffen und könnt ihr alle gerne rumkommen.
Das werden wir dieses Mal nicht machen, wir haben da keinen Bock drauf. Stefan war zwei Wochen krank, weil er einen Fan angefasst hat.
Ach, ich hab nach Fan gestunken.
Und das wollen wir nicht wiederholen. Und noch vielen Dank an Lennart für das fantastische Intro.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut und ich würde sagen frohe Ostern an der Stelle.
Frohe Ostern, schönen Freitag.
Ja, lasst euch gut gehen, Menschen, wir heben ab.